buenas tardes realmente estoy muy
emocionada de estar acá con ustedes hoy
y bueno hoy les quiero hablar sobre
este tema que creo que nos afecta a
todos
y les quiero invitar a que vean este
cuadro esta foto de
chicles pero que son chicles y caramelos
de diferentes colores
probablemente observando esta esta foto
no no pensemos que haya una
predominancia de colores o sea puede ser
que veamos chicles verdes amarillos
y morados con una cantidad equitativa
más o menos ahora que pasan usando esta
este ejemplo qué pasa si nosotros
comenzamos a tener experiencias si
comenzamos a tener vivencias que se
relacionen con el color amarillo
pueden ser experiencias que sean
intensas pueden ser que sean
experiencias que sean significativas de
aprendizaje a lo largo de nuestra vida
pueden ser que sean experiencias
repetitivas importantes entonces que
puede pasar si nuestro contacto con el
color amarillo es de esta manera
podemos llegar a pensar que el mundo es
más amarillo de lo que realmente es a
eso le llamamos sesgos cognitivos en
portugués creo que es beige con de
chivos es una manera recortada de ver la
realidad
como se genera es una es una manera
interesante porque en realidad tener
sesgos cognitivos no son buenos ni malos
por lo general son buenos son
interesantes porque porque nos da una
ventaja evolutiva como seres humanos
tener una visión recortada de lo más
importante entonces qué pasa la
información que tenemos nosotros todos
los días desde que nacemos o quizás
antes todo lo que nuestro cerebro es
estar preparado para captar esa
información y esa enorme cantidad de
datos es filtrado diariamente para que
tomemos la las decisiones más
importantes y que no nos ocurra que nos
levantemos todos los días y tengamos que
establecer criterios para decidir lo que
es más importante para nosotros nosotros
ya lo hacemos de manera automática
entonces
y ocurre esto bueno nuestra mente es
maravillosa
enamorada de la mente humana creo que
por eso elegí esta profesión a lo largo
de nuestra vida nosotros tenemos
mecanismos de aprendizaje
entonces aprendemos a relacionar
casi todo con todo nuestros nuestros
aprendizajes se dan de manera relacional
en donde asociamos experiencias con
elementos quizás neutros y juntos toman
un valor importante cuando se dan de una
manera intensa o de una manera
significativa este es un famoso
experimento en lo que es la psicología
cognitiva en donde se le pregunta a los
se les pregunto y les pregunto a ustedes
que si se le puede dar un nombre a una
de las dos figuras uno es boba y el otro
es kick y es probable que la mayoría
pensemos que golfa es el que tiene los
bordes redondeados y que quiere el que
tiene los bordes angulosos es muy
probable porque porque aprendimos que
boba es una palabra que tienen una letra
b que tiene bordes redondeados y por
asociación directa lo
es probable que lo asignemos a la figura
redondea este es un ejemplo de cómo
opera nuestra mente y cómo le damos un
significado que es quizás completamente
arbitrario
[Música]
entonces dentro de lo que son los sesgos
cognitivos que en realidad son
muchísimos no percibimos la realidad tal
cual es lo siento le comunico en
realidad lo que nosotros percibimos es
aquello que es importante para cada uno
de nosotros dentro de esos sesgos
estamos en la
en la dentro de los pensamientos tenemos
los pensamientos distorsionados es un
tipo de sesgo cognitivo y entre ellos
está la abstracción selectiva la
abstracción selectiva es prestarles
atención exclusiva o preponderante a
cierta cantidad de elementos dejando el
contexto o dejando el resto del lado
ahora les quiero está este pensamiento
este tipo de de pensamiento me pareció
muy útil traerles hoy acá me pareció
interesante porque está una vivencia que
tenemos todos y se relaciona con nuestra
vida online con nuestra vida en internet
que es a lo que nos
es lo que está presente constantemente
con nosotros creo que la mayoría de
nosotros pasamos mucho tiempo dentro de
nuestras redes sociales haciendo
búsquedas por google viendo correos
leyendo los periódicos y hay un
algoritmo gigantesco que se encarga de
procesar esos datos porque todos son
datos todos nosotros damos otorgamos
datos a internet con cada interacción
que tenemos nuestra visita a este local
puede ser registrado por nuestro
teléfono y de hecho eso va a servir como
un dato en el momento de seleccionar por
ejemplo la publicidad que me llegue a mí
o que les llegue a ustedes en sus
correos en su bandeja de en su página de
noticias de facebook en lo que les
figura en twitter entonces la big data
es increíble es un
algoritmo gigantes con software muy muy
complejo que procesa a esa cantidad de
datos y nos ofrece una experiencia
personalizada lo que ustedes ven en sus
redes sociales lo que cada uno de
ustedes ve no es lo mismo que ve el
vecino o que veo yo
cada uno tiene una experiencia en
internet personalizada sobre lo que le
es importante entonces la big data
funciona más o menos de manera analógica
a lo que funciona nuestra mente
abstrayendo selectivamente aquello que
es importante y eso es
general es bueno ahora les quiero hablar
sobre ansiedad sobre esta emoción que
todos sentimos que probablemente todos
estamos muy familiarizados con eso
algunos más otros menos depende de las
situaciones créanme que yo estoy estuve
muy familiarizada y quizás estoy ahora
con esta emoción esta emoción tiene que
ver con evaluaciones automáticas de
peligro o de daño
eso puede ser presente o sea podemos
estar atentos a situaciones de peligro
en este momento o sobre el futuro
pensando en algo que podría hacernos
daño o podría o podríamos pasar mal
simplemente pasar mal
ahora qué pasa eso es normal todos
tenemos ansiedad es algo bueno es algo
que nos ayuda a sobrevivir la ansiedad
es tan buena que es la emoción que nos
ayuda a la sobrevivencia porque nos
ayuda a calcular los riesgos por ejemplo
si tenemos un examen esta semana o la
próxima semana es probable que la
mayoría de nosotros estemos ansiosos y
que lo que hace la ansiedad nos motoriza
a movernos para estudiar y para
prepararnos hasta ahí estamos súper bien
pero qué pasa cuando nuestros
pensamientos se vuelven demasiado
catastróficos de catastrofismos es un
pensamiento automático distorsionado con
respecto
las probabilidades de las cosas que las
cosas nos puedan salir mal cuando una
persona tiene un trastorno de ansiedad
por lo general presenta este tipo de
pensamiento en donde no solo piensa que
algo malo va a salir sino que si pasa
eso malo va a ocurrir lo peor y esa
forma de procesar
lo que ocurre la realidad se presenta
muy a menudo y de manera muy intensa
cómo se relaciona todo esto con lo que
es la big data
[Música]
qué pasa cuando aquello que nos preocupa
comenzamos a buscar en internet a ver la
mayoría de nosotros probablemente y de
ustedes haga lo mismo que pasa cuando se
sienten mal o tienen algunos síntomas
buscamos en el doctor google como dice
un vecino sí doctor google donde
soluciona busquen en yahoo o sea que
generalmente comenzamos a buscar ahí por
ejemplo si nos preocupamos por
enfermarnos si nos preocupamos por la
seguridad si nos preocupamos por el
aumento de enfermedades mentales qué es
lo que hacemos cómo estamos a prestar
atención a aquello que nos pueda dar
información sobre eso entonces buscamos
en google sobre enfermedades si aparece
en facebook una noticia o un contacto
compartió algo sobre eso le damos
lectura entonces
que creen que comienza a operar en ese
momento
[Música]
la big data con sus algoritmos potentes
comienzan a registrar esas experiencias
esas búsquedas como
cosas importantes y que lo que ocurre se
selecciona aquello que nosotros
comenzamos a buscar para ofrecernos
porque se entiende que si empezamos con
búsquedas de cosas que nos preocupan
esas cosas son importantes para nosotros
entonces qué es lo que ocurre comenzamos
a percibir no sólo de manera sesgada
lo que vemos sino que nos ofrecen de
manera sesgada lo la realidad y
comenzamos a creer que esa realidad está
cada vez más grande en mi consultorio yo
escucho mucho el doctor está lleno de
tal enfermedad yo todo el día veo eso en
mi facebook claro porque ocurre que eso
que se ofrece eso que vemos en nuestra
bandeja de entrada eso que los
periódicos publican se nos va a
presentar con mayor frecuencia cuando
nosotros le le damos entrada a esas
búsquedas
entonces que podemos hacer en realidad
lo que les propongo tiene que ver con
casi todos los pensamientos que
podríamos tener de manera distorsionada
y que nos hacen mal porque los
pensamientos en sí los sesgos cognitivos
no son malos ni buenos pero si son pro
producen malestar cuando están de manera
exagerada entonces esta es una fórmula
que yo les invito a ustedes cuando
ustedes abran su facebook o vayan a
twitter o abran su bandeja de entrada de
correo tener conciencia que aquello que
está ahí que aquello que se presenta
quizás sea lo que nosotros estamos
buscando y no la realidad la realidad
quizá tenga otros elementos
y ahí comencemos a dudar sé que esto
todo como será una consecuencia de lo
que yo estoy buscando
y así con la mayoría de los temas cuáles
serían las evidencias que tengo a favor
que por supuesto vamos a tener muchas
evidencias pero es muy probable que
también podamos buscar evidencias en
contra lo que son las implicancias tiene
que ver con si yo sigo así es y yo sigo
dándole lectura buscando en google sobre
cosas que me preocupan es muy probable
que eso que se me devuelve que eso que
internet medio vuelva sea
exponencialmente mayor de lo que en
realidad existe entonces las
conveniencias de empezar a tener otro
tipo de búsquedas otro tipo que
aumentemos nuestro nuestros intereses
que tengamos otro tipo de entradas de
lecturas quizás nos ayude a balancear un
poco ya tener una visión un poco más
realista un poco más realista porque la
verdad que la realidad está diseñada
según nuestros intereses y eso es
también una manera de que nuestro
teléfono nuestra computadora pueda ser
una fuente salud o henna puede ser una
fuente de salud entonces esto que les
traigo es quizás les pueda ayudar ojalá
que sí
muchísimas gracias por escucharme